yeah welcome to this video playing a la
carte from Austria right yes austria and
okay the id-5 is good for wide I guess
but still let's go for a Sicilian why
not yeah okay let's let's take him I
vaguely remember the theory of the slide
but really just weekly ok yeah taken 96
I guess check yeah yeah yeah now Queen
f2 is the threat and I think i recently
had this well happened after Queen a3
ignored the idea c5 winning a piece
let's see if this happens again some
other seems to be an easy to miss trick
back then my opponent was a pretty good
player he overlooked c5 let's see
he's taking some time so probably he he
spotted the idea
you would have thought he spotted the
idea but he didn't I'm sorry I'm
laughing but this is funny I just just
just very a short while ago I I want a
piece exactly the same way yeah not much
you can do Quincy 725 try for revenge
check but um okay let's um let's
consider probably better take it with
developing the queen e five can I can
play em I can play Queen Queen three
okay so here Queen g3 probably the
easiest Queen 85 I can play Bishop T to
the rock on v8 is hanging some check no
the ADA's hanging orgy forms but be
eight mostly check
hmm yeah Queen if I take he's got Queen
Queen it's got night 95 I think I'll
just check I'll just be fine with an
extra look black resigned it's funny
this is this c5 trick um really a keeps
keeps getting points black black needs
to play c5 himself I guess she should be
fine not sure what what the other guy
played not rugby aid I think but it's
just just a piece what what can you do
short with you but those games are
happening as well thanks for watching